the very last Thursday so first of all
I'd like to thank the organizers for
even inviting a Bayesian statistician
here so and and I'm gonna give a talk
which is gonna have a lot of pictures
because it's the last talk
there'll be a few equations but we'll
try to keep that to a minimum and I'd
like to thank my collaborators on the
theory part Justin Magary who is at
University of Albany and Kate Turner
who's at the Australian National
University and my colleague at do a Duke
Doug Boyer who's a morphologist and then
on the more applied end which will be at
the end warren Crawford is at Brown and
Anthea
Minogue rel ramadhan and Andrew Chen are
all at Columbia okay
so I'm going to start with a picture and
so this is from Stephen Jay Gould and
the point I'm trying to make here is
that one of the geniuses of Darwin and I
think thought that led towards evolution
is pre Darwin the systematists and
people who are studying organisms and
classifying them fell under the lineal
system the lineal system of
classification and they're what you had
were these platonic ideals of objects
you had the ideal wolf you had the ideal
dog you had these ideal blah blah blah
blah blah and the point I'm trying to
make here is that Darwin started saying
well the interesting thing is not the
ideal its variation so what I'm really
interested in is variation in shape and
in this case I was variation in the
shape of a beak for my colleague Doug
he's interested in the variation in
bones these are specifically heel bones
and these are of various extinct and
extant primates okay so we might wonder
understand variation in this and one of
the reasons we might want to do this if
I can tell you how similar these bones
are I can build a similarity matrix and
from that I can build a tree now I can
ask the question how does this tree made
from these traits or phenotypes differ
from a phylogenetic tree and this might
ask starts suggesting the question was
there selective pressure on the shape or
this train so there's a question we will
come back to but we'd like to get to now
there's this picture that I want you to
have in your
ahead and we'll come back to this and
this is of thinking about evolutionary
trees as broccoli so if I live out here
along the Leafs and these florets this
shape is probably really similar to this
shape and maybe even add if you morphism
or a continuous transformational work
but if I come all the way down here - an
old ancestral organism and then come
back a few morphisms or something smooth
may no longer be meaningful in terms of
a change in the shape right so that's a
picture I want you to have in your head
okay so that's why broccoli is here if I
come back here yes yes thank you yes
this is a property of broccoli but I'm
decorating the florets of broccoli with
shapes well I'll be doing a lot of
decorating things throughout the talk so
classically there are three models of
shapes the first is Kendall's shape
space and I'll touch on that the second
is this idea of diffeomorphisms
and it goes back to the kind of this
green and ER school of continuous
transformations and a variational
problem and the third approach which
will be very much like what I'm going to
talk about really comes from the people
who studied random fields and so this is
Keith Worsley did a lot of this work
when he was studying MRI and it's
looking at dispersion sense so I'm going
to come back to thinking about excursion
sets and integral geometry okay we'll
get back to that okay so back in the day
the way Kendall thought about shapes is
you put down a bunch of landmarks okay
and then once you have these landmarks
you put a vector at each landmark and
you just stack them together and this
gives you a matrix and its similarity
between two shapes are distances between
these two matrices modulo rotations
translations and scalings so this is
formally what shape spaces these are the
landmarks and the pro Krusty's distance
between two shapes is just the squared
distance modulo these rotations and this
actually forms a space which is
technically not a manifold because it
has cusps and dimension three and above
but this was shape space now
what is now interesting and true is that
it's not like the old days where your
data is you'd go to the British Museum
you'd take an object artifact put down
five points and say hey these are other
five points and how similar are the five
points right yeah take it up with
Kendall well what do you was saying is
that for any two objects right his idea
was to shapes okay so the way that he
thought and I think it's actually
reasonable to think is that you have
biological variation and you have
technical variation and what do you call
technical variation where things that
were the same modulo scale rotation and
translation right otherwise he said
they're different now it could be for
one object and another object you could
have different ones between pairs right
so this is typically done pairwise I
will talk about touch on later on what
happens if you have a bunch of shapes
and you want to do it across all of them
that's a much harder problem okay okay
so what we have now a really nice
database is where we actually have a
bunch of CT scan so we have much richer
data than these five points on you know
from the British Museum and I wanted to
show you two pictures these are what you
can download right this is some like
toad like organism right and you could
actually go download the CT scan and if
you actually look at the data itself
this is what it looks like the data
itself this is called an off file you
get a bunch of three coordinates in
three dimensions and then you get okay
0.8 0.7 and point zero get map together
in a fits right so you get these
coordinates and how they mesh together
in a face and the point I'm trying to
make here are these data come as
simplicial complexes and if you don't
know what that is I'll define it in a
second but that's the intuition I want
you to get
now another approach and this is
something that my colleague Doug Boyer
and ingrid daubechies have been working
on and I've been working with them is
the divya morphism paste approach so I
take my shape I put down a bunch of
landmarks I put a little ball around
that landmark and then I define a
variational distance between these two
right and and you know this is one way
of thinking about it now I'll come back
to this in a second but I'm gonna use
topology in a little bit and I just
always like adding this picture which is
why would anyone use topology to model
shapes cuz our coffee cup is the same as
a doughnut right this seems silly but
the point I'm trying to make is that
homeomorphisms are stronger or weaker
than diffeomorphisms and the point I'm
making is a lot of these data so these
are fly wings David who is a statistical
geneticist and these are normal flies
and these are mutants and what you see
they're qualitative differences you add
lobes you lose leaves right so it's very
hard to actually do it if you're
morphisms between these because they're
qualitatively different pictures among
some of these okay for example here
we've lost this lobe so what we're
interested in is can we model shapes
without requiring landmarks or different
morphisms and our approach is going to
be to transform the data into a
representation that they can use
standard statistical models for ideally
this transformation should be subjective
so you shouldn't lose information this
transformed space should be nice some
cases will be a matrix and I should be
able to pull back from the transform
space so whatever I infer in this
transformed space I should be able to
pull back and say something about the
original object so these are my goals
okay great
I'm going to use two topological
summaries to use this Euler
characteristic and persistent homology
I'll demonstrate them by picture us you
might define them but let me first build
up what is a shape or what I think of as
a shake so these are simplices does a
point is a zero simplex line is one
simplex this is a two simplex tetrahedra
three simplex some policial complex is
just a collection of simplicity's or all
the phases are in the simplex and
simplicity's intersect along common
faces so I'll give you examples of
what's not a simplicial complex you
can't just take this and stick it in the
middle that's not allowed
I can't delete a node and I can't delete
an edge so these are examples of
simplicial complexes so my less abstract
definition of a shape is going to be a
simplicial complex and I showed you
that's my mesh that's my data now when
we worked on this we also thought of a
much more abstract version because I was
working with topologists like a category
theory but this will be one of the more
technical slides it's not so horribly
important but what this is telling you
is this is a definition of basically
measurability for sets so what you're
doing is you start out in 1d and you say
you're just looking at finite unions
above open intervals okay then you go to
2d so you have a product space and
you're just saying when I project back
into any of the one dimensions I still
have this kind of definition of a shape
okay so this is a basic construction
which is not so important now what I'm
going to tell you is there constructible
sets these are collections of compact
definable subsets of Rd that are tame
have nice properties this is an
important idea constructible functions
these are integer valued functions such
that every level set is tame
what do I mean by that is if I just
sweep through a function the number of
critical points or the smoothness of
this is somehow constrained and I'll
make that more rigorous in a little bit
okay
now one of the objects we're going to
use a lot is something called a height
function so this is my bone this is a
plane and I'm gonna think about sweeping
this plane through the bone I'm gonna do
it for many directions so this is
specifically a CT scan of a mouse heart
embryo and I've swept distance a and I'm
looking at the sublevel set of that and
what I'm going to compute from that
subset level set is something called the
Euler characteristic so in the case of a
mesh in three dimensions the Euler
characteristic is just the number of
vertices minus the number of edges plus
the number of faces so this is a
topological invariant so far all these
filled in objects the Euler
characteristics to for a donut or a
torus at zero and for swiss-cheese it's
negative 34 okay that's not so formal
okay so if I were to take a hand and I
would just sweep from the bottom up this
would be what's called the Euler
characteristic curve so that's as I
sweep through this is telling me how the
Euler characteristic is changing and
this is just a smooth version of this
basically I subtract alpha mean and I
integrate no I'll give you the formula
in a little bit the Euler characteristic
curve is changing at critical points so
it's really in a way of counting or
collecting the critical points so that's
always telling you okay the other
summary is something called persistent
homology so homology in general Bettye
zero is a number of connected components
that he 1 is the number of 1 cycles
betty 2 is a number of voids right so if
you take the sphere hollow it out it's
one connected component there's no one
cycle and there's one void what's
amazing is these can all be computed
using linear algebra and that's kind of
the beauty of the work of any node ur so
I'm going to give you a three-minute
introduction to Moore's theory
ok so pretend I'm back in North Carolina
well maybe I can pretend it back in
North Carolina and there's a flood and
the water is rising and what I'm
interested in is when something changes
in terms of the connected components of
the image down here so the first thing
that happens is you hit this valley
you go a little bit further you hit
another Valley go a little bit further
you hit this valley
now the next things that's gonna happen
is you get to this peak and this is
gonna merge with this right so this has
just born there's this feature that's
born you go a little bit further it dies
and similarly you can go through this
whole thing and these births and its
deaths which are based basically
pairings of critical points give you a
summary and this is called a persistence
diagram okay another way of thinking
about this as you deserve as a
filtration I take my data I slowly
thicken it and I start asking one does
topology or homology change and so if
you look at these nestings you just
asking when do these homology groups
change persistence diagram another way
of thinking about it is a countable
multi set of points and the diagonal has
infinite multiplicity so if I give you
two curves the red curve and the blue
curve this will be the corresponding
diagrams and I can define distances
between these diagrams using an l2
Vasher stein metric so I'm just saying
what's the cost for moving the red
points to the blue points and anything I
can't match I just match to the diagonal
okay so this is one metric I'm not
saying it's a best metric but this is a
common metric used okay it turns out
that from these this two Vasher stein or
the infinity version which is sometimes
called the bottleneck distant distance
there's a stability property so if the
curves are closed right the ensuing
diagrams will be kind of closed this
doesn't necessarily go in the other
direction and we'll talk a little bit
about that now formally this Euler
characteristic curve is basically you're
thinking about its sphere I'm taking
directions on the sphere and I'm mapping
it to these constructible functions
these things that jump as integers okay
now another way of saying this is take
your mesh go go in Direction V okay go
distance T look at the sublevel a side
of that intersect that with the mesh and
compute the other characteristic so
that's formally what we call the Euler
characteristic transformed
similarly there's a smoother Euler
characteristic transform so you take the
Euler characteristics subtract after me
and integrate it okay now what's
interesting here is I've turned a mesh
into a collection of curves in l2 now as
a statistician what's nice about that is
I've taken my problem back to functional
data analysis we think about and we have
tools for modeling functions and l2 yeah
so this is integrating well we'll get to
that yes you want it
this is integrating over the sweep the
sweep okay yeah and you can do the same
thing with the persistent homology you
take any direction you get a diagram
right you're just kind of doing that 2d
picture of that Moore's function
actually no you could do it that way in
this case it's actually sweeping up
through the thing so if I showed you so
it's in the 3d version it's just
sweeping through the object okay so it's
really like the Morse function okay yeah
I know how big my shapes are right
because like I get them
okay
now just for anyone who cares there is a
commutative diagram between the
persistent Amala G transform and the
Euler characteristic form and all this
says is that the Euler characteristic
transform has less information than the
persistent homology transform and now
since we are in a robust statistics
workshop I should say something about
robustness okay so in a way the
persistent homology transform has some
Lipchitz property the Euler
characteristic transform does not but
the Euler characters transform when you
smooth it lends to something that's l2
you can work in l2 and work with curves
whereas the space of persistence
diagrams is terrible it doesn't have
unique Geo d6 and there are a lot of
problems with it and again part of the
reason why we're going to these integral
transformation ideas is to be robust
with respect to these lack of different
morphisms so I can now define distances
between shapes that are not necessarily
different morphic I take the smooth
Doyler characteristic transform in any
direction just measure the altitude norm
of the curves and integrate it over the
entire sphere now what this means and
doesn't mean we'll come back to but this
is one way of measuring distance and I
could do the same thing with the
persistent homology transform take a
direction compute persistent homology of
rank K so Betty kV equals zero would be
connected components K one would be
number of one cycles measure this
distance and integrated over the sphere
now there's this question which is my
computer does not want to integrate over
the sphere it turns out it doesn't like
that right so you can ask a question
about how many directions and we'll come
back to this and you can ask a question
is this transform invertible right so
this is related to a classic idea which
is called the radon transform so if I
had the way people get micro CT scans
and these meshes typically is you take
an object and you radiate it for many
many many many different directions and
you reconstruct it okay now there's a
very beautiful result which kind of
tells you this is called shapira's and
and this is probably the most general
version of one you can invert the radon
transform and it involves fiber bundles
and sheaves and it's very abstract so I
won't just tell you that this is a
theorem it exists you can read about it
now what we can do is we can use
shapira's inversion theorem to tell you
that both of these transforms are
injective you don't lose information if
you take all directions now initially
kate myself and doug proved this without
using shapira's inversion theorem in
dimensions 2 & 3 by actually coming up
with a pseudo algorithm that did this it
was like a very much geometric
brute-force algorithm ik like thing then
we realize you can just use shapira's
inversion theorem and so that's what we
did in this paper and over on the
similar time Rob Christ and two of her
students showed something similar okay
now how many directions we found for
dimension two you can use 162 directions
and for dimension 3 you need 700
directions those are very precise
numbers now there's a more serious
question which is how do I think about
this more rationally right how do I
think about the number of directions I
need and and think about this problem
and that's what I'm going to spend the
next stop 15 minutes telling you about
yeah I was actually joking ok right I'm
just empirically when we ran our code
and did this unreal data which I'll show
you later in three dimensions we did use
702 directions and in two dimensions we
used 162 this is not yet principal right
and this this goes back to actually that
the title of this top how many
directions characterize a shape or a
family of shapes so we want to think
about a sampling theory for shapes what
is some notion of a complexity metric
first set of shapes okay right there's a
beautiful paper by Arnold and he asked
the following question if I tell you
where the critical points are of a
function right can you tell me how many
homological different functions exist
that satisfy having those critical
points and he gives a closed form
solution for this which is amazing and
just closed-form solution it's very hard
to extend this to 2d because what he
does is completely dependent on ordering
and as we know ordering becomes harder
when you go to dimension beyond one so
how do we think about this problem okay
so what we first do is we constrain this
shape of the shapes I'm going to tell
you my space of shapes are the set of
all and blended out embedded simplicial
complex k and RD and they have the
following two properties at every vertex
there's a lower bound on curvature I'll
call that Delta and I'm going to tell
you in any direction that I sweep it
there's a maximum number of critical
points okay so these are the two
constraints that I need given these two
constraints this is how many directions
you need so if you want to play 500
million questions right and you give me
a family of shapes these are the number
of directions that you need to be able
to tell apart shapes okay I'm going to
talk a little bit about how one gets
this and what this has to do with the VC
dimension okay
so first there's a resolution parameter
you notice there's this one plus two
over Delta to the D and this is a number
of points we need to get a delta cover
of the sphere now you might say it's
weird why do you need a lower bound on
curvature not an upper bound on
curvature and it turns out if you think
about this for a while it's really hard
to tell apart two things that are near
flat like if you give me a pancake and
you give me I don't know Street in
Amarillo Texas right it's kind of really
hard to tell this apart just by sweeping
in directions whereas if you give me of
something really curved a lot of
directions will start into
differentiating things so that's what's
going on here this is giving you the
number of delta covers required to
determine all the vertices of the shape
using only the euler curves from the
union of these delta notes that's how we
get this now I didn't tell you what W X
is and so I need to draw an important
picture and I'll come back to that
picture later so here's how you should
think about this I'm about to draw the
sphere so Demetri told me to draw a
sphere so I drew a sphere okay and and
and and the idea is what are we doing
we're sweeping in a direction V along
the sphere right and any direction on
the sphere I'm quite am I gonna get I'm
gonna get one of these Euler curves
right okay which I'm just going to not
write like this I'm gonna think about it
as a bunch of points and this is just
where the critical points change that's
all you got oiler characteristic curve
it's it's just telling me where these
critical points change now let's call
this direction V one if I take a small
cone around v1 and get another direction
v2 and if that cone is small enough or
not small enough means is what the meat
you are saying which is based on that
curvature then let's call this t1
there's going to be a similar t2 which
I'm not going to draw but there's a
linear relation between this t1 and t2
and this is just a result of projective
geometry right so for a small enough
region so what I'm really doing is I'm
taking the sphere and I'm chopping it up
with hyperplanes I'm doing a hyperplane
partition of the sphere is really the
structure right and all I need to do is
the one of these in each partition
because if I know one there's a linear
function that gives me all of the others
and the number of partitions I need is W
of X and you can basically bound that
and basically which is by the union of X
choose two and this gives you a bound on
the hyperplanes and immediately
basically you get a VC result because
you apply the Sowers salak lemma to that
okay so so that's how this cardinality
is coming in okay now one interesting
idea that we're working on is actually
building likelihood models on these
shapes so if I can basically make a
random mixture model or I pick a random
Direction V one model this right get
different random partitions think of
this as a mixture model this is a
distribution on shape space on this
module I space of shapes I just need to
pull it back to the original space and
I'll talk about that later okay
now you might want to do everything in a
rotation invariant way right things that
I did now are not rotation invariant
because the directions have to line up
so this is push forwards of measures but
just think about this way take any
direction think of it as random I get a
curve right now I have a bunch of random
curves for shape one I have a bunch of
curves random curves for shape two you
have two choices fit a distribution look
at the different some notion of
divergence right or look at these as
empirical measures and do an optimal
transport right so this is a theory that
says that will go through if there's
some generic properties of these objects
and we're actually implementing this and
see how empirically while it works now
the reason why I went to smooth Euler
characteristic curve is we wanted to
build possibly likelihood models
right so this is an exponential family
model so if I have K curves one from
each direction what I could do I have
two choices one I can discretize them
each curve now have a matrix now I've
taken a shape and turned it into a
matrix very abnormal problem right so
this is a shape now I model it by a mean
of the matrix mu is modeling the
covariance between the curves V is
modeling the covariances between points
in a curve and this is a likelihood
model for shapes which is not easy to
write in the actual space of shapes if
you don't want to discretize you can
model this as a Gaussian process and
I'll come back to ideas plate related
here later so these are calcaneus from
two different angles and here's real
data I have the heel bones of these 106
primates okay
some of them extinct some of them are
extent I compute the persistent homology
transform I get pairwise distances
I do multi-dimensional scaling and
embedded in two dimensions that's how
you get this picture and these are all
great apes this is a lesser a so you
start seeing these are kind of folding
together this is not a spider it's a
spider monkey okay this is a baboon but
cactuses and this is an extinct old
world monkey so all of these except for
the spider monkey or old warm old
old-world monkeys these are all new
world monkeys this is an extinct new
world monkey this is a squirrel monkey
not a squirrel and these are all lemurs
so you start seeing something that you
expect evolutionarily and so this is my
picture of my colleague Doug made which
looks better and also starts telling you
what tax said these belong to okay now
this is a well of my two comments so one
of the things that Doug told me is that
at least in one way this was better and
that high labayda's worm now matched
with apes and previously high/low babies
were with the Oulu atom so I got this
email and I had no idea what it meant
now it turns out well my wife is a
biologist so she explained this to me
she said the Gibbons are now what the
Apes before they were with the hähnel or
monkeys
so that made Doug happy now you can take
a look at it this and this is what the
picture is that Doug made when we are
using Pro Krusty's or you know the
classic Kendall method this is add if
you morph isn't based method and this is
our method so at least visually it looks
better we also did simulations and
things like that which I won't show you
because are really boring
the original dimension I just have a
pairwise distance matrix
there's no dimension well if you give
you okay if you yeah so I have it it's
like 7000 I think so if you stack for
example all of those Euler
characteristic curves I think it's like
7000 dimensions I don't have that I have
that in the somewhere in the paper but I
don't have that yeah it would be so so
so this was you know and we've done
other comparisons there's a very
interesting math question here which is
what is a gold standard right when I ask
you questions about different morphic
shapes I have some notion of a gold
standard because I have this
transformation group when these things
are no longer too few morphic it's not
clear what is a gold standard there is
some theory there's something called a
theory of hedwig or integration and and
then something which is related to a
while it's tube formula and these are
things that Jonathan Taylor and and
Robert Adler have worked on but those
are limited to certain classes so
thinking about generalizing that is is
actually an interesting question okay it
turns out that not everyone cares about
heel bones
I think it's shocking but not everyone
cares about heel bones so we wanted to
think about can we apply these ideas to
more biomedical applications and this is
uh this is a person skull and brain and
this is a brain tumor this is a
glioblastoma and what we wanted to ask
is how much does the shape of a tumor
explain clinical variables okay and you
could ask why should it and we'll come
back to that so I have 92 patients they
have match gene expression and MRI they
this is my gene expression data this is
a set of morphometric features that
oncologists and radiologists decided to
use and they use it in a lot of these
TCGA paper where they combine imaging
with genomics these are five stupid
features like how big it is how skewed
it is and this is 7,200 so these are the
collection of our topological features
and we have two responses disease-free
survival and overall survival and we're
going to do regression we're gonna think
of the shapes as covariates in a
regression problem and we're gonna ask
which of the following best explains
variation in the clinical trait and
we're basically going to use a Gaussian
process model this is this is like the
Bayesian part of the talk but I wrote it
frequentist cuz I'm at Berkeley I'm
sorry let's find out so this is what you
get so this is R squared which is %
explained and optimal just means how
many times was one of these features
optimal when we ran them all right and
what you find is gene expression is not
that great because it's too variable the
morphometric features are pretty decent
but it turns out that this Euler
characteristic transform is doing really
well in all of these cases and what you
also find is using a heavy tailed kernel
is better right so this is kind of
interesting and that maybe there's some
utility in this and maybe we can get
some information out of it now there's a
basic question which you can ask us why
should topology tell me anything about
survival or something else about a tumor
and that's a really good question now
there is something that surgeons know if
I have a tumor and it's broken up so
betty 0 is quite large the chance of it
proliferating and becoming metastatic is
larger right something else surgeons
know which is if I have a breast cancer
and it's necrotic in the middle so it's
a shell and it's necrotic in the middle
those usually have good outcome so Betty
2 is a positive thing so what you really
trying to understand here and you need
experiments to do this is how does this
geometry relate to the molecular biology
of proliferation and the physiology of
proliferation that's kind of the
underlying question okay now this is
something we're working on right now you
can ask what parts of the shape are most
associated to variation in the trait so
basically can you do variable selection
okay so here's an example of a data set
we're working with we have 50 molars
from five different primate genrih these
are the monkeys okay and some of them
eat leaves some of them eat insects and
some of them eat fruits so this is a
classification problem so what I can do
is take the different data from the
species look at the Euler curves do
variable selection on them so match
regions and the question is can I pull
back and give you a picture like that
where in the shape you can okay so we're
working on this right now we're
debugging things so I'm not showing you
final results but the basic idea is you
can and it's a problem in projective
geometry so let's say this is my shape
it's just a parabola it's very simple
and what I'm doing is I'm just looking
at I know the direction I'm going in I
know where there's a critical point
right so let's say I highlight that I go
to a position really near by a cone
really near by I look at where this is
hitting a look at where this is hitting
and if I take three directions or more I
can reconstruct where it is right it's
just again straight projective geometry
so this is the idea that we're using
okay now everything I've told you in a
way it's just signal processing and it's
integrals these are integrals or euler
integrals through not our standard you
know I don't know Riemann integral but
this is all signal processing so there's
no reason I need to just sweep through
the whole shape I could have done it
localized right so you can actually
think about this entirely as a signal
processing problem and you pick your
basis you can formulate the dictionary
learning problem in this where you pick
sub shapes or small shapes and you
comprised your shapes and we're trying
to do this actually to do to simulate
interesting shapes
I mentioned this so this is a problem I
really want to work on so the classic
idea in phylogenetics is I get a bunch
of sequences I have a likelihood model
and a substitution model right between
these letters alphabet letters now in a
way I gave you one likelihood model now
there's a question of what is a natural
substitution model for shapes right
doing Ornstein Oland back on shapes
might be weird because you don't want
them to cross each other right so
thinking about what is a natural
substitution model here I think is
really interesting so there's a picture
that I didn't show you one way of
thinking about what I told you and also
the way of thinking about the diffusion
of shapes is that this is a shape this
is a shape this is a shape this is a
shape this is a shape this is shape it
lives on a manifold maybe maybe it
doesn't okay and there's a graph which
kind of tells you which shapes are kind
of close to each other and above each
shape I decorated with something so I
could decorate it with the landmarks I
could decorate it with tangent spaces
right if I decorate it with tangents
this would be a tangent bundle I could
generalize this to general fiber bundles
and all I'm saying is that if I go from
here to here to here right and if I get
back let's say I went here here here and
then I went back to here okay if I get
back the identity right then I've done
parallel transport and all of these are
flat okay which means that they live on
a little you know nice little floret of
broccoli okay now what happens if you go
from here to here let's say here and try
to come back here you may not get the
identity this graph may be broken there
might not be a trivial flat section
across all of this graph which is why
it's a few morphism approach may not
work and may work locally and not
globally and so one way of thinking
about this is what happens if I
decorated these with these oiler
characteristics right does this give me
another way of thinking about
integration theory and how are these
related right so that's that's also a
question there
okay if you want I can tell you how
we're using this in meerkats but uh but
I can also can also tell you this is
people who did stuff people I talk to
and these are people who funded us and
actually there's one other thing I
wanted to say so the VC theory result
that I gave you this upper bound is
useless we all know these bounds are
typically not very useful however
there's a very interesting practical
question there which is let's say your
Siemens okay
you're a company that generates these
you know x-ray machines right and what
you know is maybe some person maybe a
patient wants to get more x-rays as they
progress through the disease but they
want to but there's a radiation budget
so now you can ask if you give me a
bunch of shapes if you give me a bunch
of you know tumors are a bunch of breast
tumors or something like that and if you
give me a radiation budget you can say
these are the directions right that you
need to give you the most information in
a way right so you know that is one of
the applications we're trying to go
towards which is a little bit more
practical than the VC dimension but in
all end unless you want to hear about
meerkats so well one of the things is
for example I was using a Gaussian
process model right for the regression
so I can use that right I can put a
prior over that covariance structure so
that the one of the slides that I was
showing you where I wanted to build this
random mixture model that's what I want
to do with it I want to generate random
shapes so I basically want to put
distributions you know over the sphere
and then use the projective geometry to
pull it back to shapes right that's
that's we're trying to do that we
haven't gotten there all right so that's
that's one of the things I do want to do
when you fulfill the full objects we
have this scan over the refugee don't
you first to align them yeah so so this
is this is to the point so everything I
showed you was unaligned shapes right
now that's one of the reasons why we're
trying to extend it to the rotation free
version when you look at the
distributions the lining shapes is a
pain in the ass so typical way of lining
shapes is you first do all pairwise
alignment and then you do something like
construct a minimum spanning tree right
then you go to the minimum spanning tree
compute distances on the minimum
spanning tree and then iterate this
until it stops right that's one
algorithm there are other ones right but
this is a really painful thing to do so
that's one of the reasons why we're
trying to go to this rotation free
version we're also trying to write out a
scale-free version because I have a
colleague who wants to compare neurons
of rats with neurons of mice and they
want to like I don't know get rid of
size they want to say that rats are just
not bigger mice I mean at that the
neuron level
yep just a little is here and I changed
over to you you don't really come from
[Music]
I think I don't know the exact answer to
that but I think what I could tell you
is if you give me the continuous things
I could probably tell you if it came
from certain some moduli space I might
be able to test that I don't know I'd
have to think about it yeah yeah yeah I
want to say yes but I also want to be
careful I will think about it and I'll
send you an email but I want to say yes
but it's not always just good to say
what you you know
[Applause]